there's an election happening in
Bangladesh but it's of secondary
importance to the estimated 2third of
households worried about Rising food and
fuel prices an economy booming just a
few years ago is now
stagnant High inflation caused in part
by the war in Ukraine means even the
middle class is
struggling experience it is difficult to
survive with these prices if they wanted
to make changes they could have done it
before I'm pessimistic that anything
will change
the election itself will make little
difference a boycott by the opposition
who say the vote will be rigged all but
guarantees the governing party a fourth
consecutive term they are not Democratic
they are stay in power only for one
party in Bangladesh so that we are not
accept this election we appeal to the
people of Bangladesh not to attend the
seventh election thank you politics in
Bangladesh has for decades been
dominated by rival dynasties led by
prime minister Sheik Hina and former
prime minister KH Zia Zia is under house
arrest on corruption charges she says
are politically motivated and her
supporters have been jailed in their
thousands after violent protests that
began last October it's not often you
see opposition parties supporters
gathered openly like this and they won't
be allowed to for long this is an
election name certainly but there's only
one political view that matters here and
it isn't theirs that's something the
aami league strongly
refutes the government is not hindering
any political party from taking part in
the election those who say we are doing
so their claims are bogus they are
false bahin Nasim is tipped for a senior
ministerial job and in his Central daaka
constituency his is by far the most
visible face fluttering in the breeze
despite his promise of a fair election
the wind is turning in Bangladesh
towards a one party State Jonah Hal Al
jazer daaka